it's time we find the rest of our
brothers and get the band back together
we're going to have the best family
reunion ever the trolls movies are
officially becoming a Trilogy so we're
going to unpack the previous trolls
movies and series and give you a look at
the latest installment that will be very
let's just say in sync with boy band
culture like I'm definitely saying hello
hello hello to this one and if you
didn't get that in sync joke I cannot
help you this is everything you need to
know before you go see trolls band
together all I ever want
I can't believe this is really happening
so today we are going to hit on four
quick topics which include a brief
history of the previous movies and shows
a look at what this installment is about
plus whose voices you can expect to hear
and what's happening on the music side
hint some pretty big things okay so
let's roll through a little trolls
history the First doll was created in
the early 1950s by a Danish wood cutter
I'm just kidding well I mean that's
actually true but we're not going to go
all all the way back there today so the
certified fresh first movie called
trolls came in 2016 and introduced anak
Kendrick's hyperactive poppy who's
forced to team up with the mega paranoid
Branch voiced by Justin Timberlake after
their Village is attacked by Bergens and
their friends are taken now they end up
forming a bond despite their differences
naturally and their lives are forever
changed now JT was also the executive
music producer of this film which
spawned his number one hit song Can't
Stop the feeling personally I can't stop
loving that song which is weird because
normally I have a really low tolerance
for music that's played everywhere but
this one is still so good for some
reason and arriving with a bang in April
of 2020 was trolls World Tour diving
deeper into the world of trolls this
fresh film features poppy teaming up
with other troll kingdoms to try and
stop the queen of hard rock trolls from
conquering all of them I mean we're
dealing with some heavy metal kids here
now of course poy did her thing and the
Jazz trolls teamed up with the K-pop and
ratone trolls and so on and so forth
forth honestly I want to be a part of
this cast and there was a big song and
dance at the end now over on the small
screen if you missed this between those
movies there was a Netflix series called
trolls the beat goes on that show
actually ran for 2 years and it follows
poppy with a different voice actress as
she gets further acquainted with her
role as Queen of the trolls and after
the trolls World Tour movie came the
show trolls Topia on peacock and Hulu
now this show features poppy further
befriending and getting to know other
troll kingdoms now that she's helped
everyone make peace yay poppy The
Peacemaker okay so now that you're all
caught up on pass installments here is
what you can expect from trolls ban
together basically it took long enough
but Poppy and Branch are finally
officially a couple I mean I got to say
I love a slowburn except when it's in my
life but like any good relationship
she's learning major new things about
him way too far into it like for
instance it turns out that Branch was
once in Poppy's favorite boy band with
his brothers called brozone I mean you
think that would have came up on a first
date sadly the group broke up when he
was still a baby and so did the family
and Branch hasn't seen his broone Bros
since and after one of his brothers is
kidnapped for his musical talents by a
pair of pop star villains it's up to
branch and Poppy to get the brothers and
maybe even the band back together to
save the day let's talk about the voices
though here's a look at who you'll be
hearing during this Whirlwind of fun so
joining the leads Kendrick and Justin
Timberlake this time around are a bunch
of recognizable voices and names ranch's
brothers and BR Zone include Eric Andre
Deb Diggs kid Cy and Electro pop star
Troy Savon but Branch isn't the only one
meeting past family because we're also
going to get to know Poppy's long lost
older sister viva played by Camila Cabo
meanwhile those pop star villains that I
was telling you about velvet and veneer
they're voiced by Amy Schumer and Andrew
ranold respectively and making their
triumphant return from past movies or
people like Zoe de Chanel Christopher
mint PL Anderson pack Rue Paul Canal
naier Keenan Thompson and the members of
Icona poop among others I mean it is a
stacked cast okay let's talk about my
favorite part now the music music always
plays a huge part of these movies and
this time let's just say it's pretty
major and that is because we learned
after the release of the film's second
trailer that legendary boy band in sync
led by Justin Timberlake would be
reuniting and doing an original song for
the film called better place which if
you're keeping track like I am at home
is their first new track in 22 years I'm
not old you're old but but also every 9s
kids dream and another single from the
soundtrack that's been released is
called it takes two which is performed
by Cabo and Anna Kendrick well friends
that is everything you need to know
before you go see trolls band together
in theaters on November 17th get your
phones out and scan that QR code so you
can buy your tickets now my name is as
Perez and thank you for watching this
video be sure to check out our other no
Before You Go episodes so you're all
ready to go before you head to the
theater or watch a big show we got your
back as always be sure to rate and
review this film at Rotten tomatoes.com
we love knowing how you feel and
[Music]
[Applause]
think